hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to mind scanners
[Music]
that's right they want to use my
daughter as well okay so we were in the
middle
of curing
this person mandari kumara who has
moved again why that's fine
any of these guys closer oh you are
technically closer
zx 81 appeared out of nowhere a few days
ago he claims to be a robot but even the
most untrained i will see through this
act
well you're closer so um i kind of am
inclined but i
could finish the cure here
like i could definitely thin maybe not
actually let me do this one
might as well go ahead and meet all the
people that i can as opposed to john's
jumping straight to something else halt
citizen state your business do your work
for sinclair research
no then who are you
i'm a mind scanner i see i don't have a
mind to scan but you might be able to
access my central processing unit
if you want to look inside the workings
of a cutting edge machine
be my guest okay i'll do exactly that
let me take a look at your machine brain
a bunch of stuff on a conveyor belt
and some woman waiting for me to scan
her soda bottles i think i was hard
because of my heightened skill of
scanning objects
sounds like a boring job shards of glass
on the floor
i escaped my glass cage running from my
creators did they fear my
unimaginable strength and catastrophic
powers fear not mother
fear not father i am a good son
[Music]
run away has great powers yeah okay
this is what i look like on the inside
intricate circuit board
mechanical pistons valuable technology
especially in the wrong hands
no wonder they're all looking for me
this google plier
something like this it's pretty on the
inside not so much on the outside but
pretty on the inside um
most wanted and that doesn't feel right
nah i didn't feel right it was gonna be
pretty on the robot he's a robot
someone's face reflected in a window
i'm washing the window maybe that's how
i would look
if i were a human wants to be human he
doesn't want to be human
sees himself well i knew that
these the answers to these are sometimes
a little strange and not
entirely cohesive with what i think it
will be the training facility they
taught me how to perform human functions
janitorial work mostly cleaning windows
and such what a waste of all my powerful
cpu
lousy job yep okay
easy enough well you're patently insane
an underlying dissatisfaction with the
job seems to be causing this individual
to escape from reality and take the
personality of zx81
robot fugitive a robot fugitive
really well a little bit insane rob
identity
that's a lot of insane i don't have that
one but i might be able to make it
and a dreamer okay you got it
i have a system error maybe it's a virus
or some sort of trojan
i can run a diagnostic program whatever
you do don't take me back to sinclair
okay i also just had a brainwave
literally just now i didn't think about
this before but i just realized that i
can get things that aren't necessarily
in the most immediate and that kind of i
can stack them up so that i can hit them
multiple at a time okay i need
candelabra i need this thing and i need
cross so i need to go make the cross you
okay attached to the larynx this device
transforms the insanity into frequencies
and forces them out using the vocal
cords of the patient caution requires a
steady hand turn the knob to max power
nice and easy all right sounds good
let's get this going
hey how about that treatment huh sounds
good
let's do it
okay so if i do this twice
it should work out nicely right you know
what i mean
so i get that one but also i get this
other one too
there we go yeah yeah and then i do the
[Music]
candelabra
blam and then they're all gone easy
peasy
[Music]
no that's not what i want to do oh but i
got a personality
well not not quite wasn't exactly
necessary there we go
i still might not get this but it's all
good
where's your jiggly bits there we go
bam okay and then if i do the
lever
[Music]
you got it you got it
okay now i can try this freaky one
okay i did that i have no idea what that
was about
okay whatever let's get the personality
going let's go ahead and top that off
i don't know if we're going to be able
to get anything else ah
cross i guess
[Laughter]
i got it hey just in time your work day
has ended
citizen requires further treatment i
know maintenance minus seven
i really don't make a lot of money maybe
some of these people i could help could
give me a lot of money
that'd be very helpful today's news
after a lot of requests the constructor
happily announced his plans for a new
park
in the boots the park will be a hybrid
park a brand new concept
the constructor describes this techno
park as otherworldly fauna and
state-of-the-art technology
mixed in unique ways techno park is
ready in three months
okay why do you have to move why do you
all have to move
hi greetings scanner
yeah of course greetings to you
let's do the let's do the cross actually
[Music]
okay enough
bam okay
[Music]
oh the personality i almost lost that
one
all right now we're gonna do this
[Music]
yeah and then you're done good job hey
congratulations
treatment complete plus 15k
[Music]
hello i'm not sure if i'm ready to take
this box off just yet
but uh thank you for your help i
appreciate it
um i think i need to get back to work
thanks again
bye okay good i guess that went
as well as i could hope for and i'm not
even gonna have any time to fix you
what am i gonna do i'm gonna have 15
seconds to do
nothing i know you've been waiting for
treatment for a while but really trying
it's raining set
i know you've been horribly depressed
and i left
you here alone to deal with your own
thoughts and that's not cool but i did
it anyway because i'm kind of a douche
all right let's do something i guess uh
sure
the vibra i don't think i'm gonna get
these
oh hurry hurry hurry hurry hurry hurry
there it is there it is boom
got him nice
i did it i'm the best all right goodbye
later all right i've had about enough of
you
i couldn't possibly take any more of uh
being around you
so uh i'm just gonna go home and
all right got my maintenance though i
really think there's probably a better
way to be efficient about this but i'm
not doing too good
today's news a data pipe bursting in the
lower parts of the pumps today creating
a high risk of radiation
the entire district will be closed off
for traffic for the rest of the day
dude why are you why are you so far i
can't possibly help you because i gotta
go over here
uh claudia bloom is a shy young woman
with a passion for flowers she has
always drawn a little attention to
herself
all right you're gonna have to wait i'm
sorry rumors say that she has acquired
an authoritarian personality well you
are very close by so
thankfully it's your turn now hi
ah just in time i need every hand on
deck i have an important decree going
out any minute now i need my advisors
close at hand
certainly as a constructor it is my duty
to optimize the way of life for all
citizens of the structure
decisions can be hard to make yet i take
faith in the instruction
of course so why are you here
time for a mind scan hello i always
wanted to scan the mind of the
constructor
my control room from these monitors i
can keep an eye on every corner of the
structure
there's the sewage system doing just
fine it looks like
claims to govern the structure
apparently an id card a small piece of
plastic that grants the bearer power
while tracking his movements
an elegant solution after all i need to
look out for my citizens
and i can't be everywhere once thinks
she's the constructor
seems to be a one-track thing here oh
yes
my autobiography a life of structures
strange
i feel this book was a gift from my
parents
that's absurd seeing how i am the author
thinks she wrote the book
[Music]
yeah good
great claudia bloom seems to have
transposed her own identity onto that of
the constructor
a strange kind of flattery but a little
bit insane
auto mimicle all right i can do this oh
just two
well that's easy the best stower the
best tower
all right well it looks like uh that
other person is gonna have to wait
guard sees this insulin scanner
immediately cards where are you when i
need you
cards that's too late for you sorry um
but i don't have one of those but i may
be able to get away with
uh just this one because i could use
this to get rid of any of those
unless they show up but wait i do have
that oh i have that one
okay never mind oh right it's the the
eyeball thing
all right well let's do it then i guess
okay let's go this first
oh that's all eight nice easy enough
blast this one out what do you got
signed cu sign
cu blam easy
all right here we go one two three
four by the looks of it
nice blam
what do you got sign cc
sign cc you got it easy
this is easy let's get that personality
this chump personality
oh there we go what is that yeah
let's go do this next what do we got u
sine sine u sine sine
[Music]
this is super easy what do we got
c sine u c sign you
easy all right let's get that
personality
did i not get the personality lesson i
thought i did whoa
there we go you all right let's get
another dose of that
this personality ain't too uh
integritized
that is one
there you go get that personality back
up thank you
okay
[Music]
interesting one two
three one two three three yes
okay thank you you're very cured i could
have sworn there was another patient
that i had but i guess they just weren't
important enough
anyway hi how you doing what a strange
dream i had i was a constructor
so sure of myself of everything i felt
like i could see the mechanics of
everything
like clockwork so so strange did you
awaken me
yes i did pay me money please then thank
you
i have to say it was an interesting
experience but it would probably have
gotten me into trouble i'll remember to
send you some flowers
thanks doctor take care i'm a doctor
i'm a doctor i help people i'm a doctor
can i make any more of these can i make
this last one nah not enough time
converts personality into science suck
out the wisdom of your patient one
thought at a time
well that seems awfully unethical room
was all stressing personality even after
max stress oh
a robotny um let's just end the day
i'm sure there's no one that needs our
help right now we're good
let's end the day yeah you received a
lovely bouquet of roses from miss bloom
along with the note thanks for letting
me stop and smell the roses
the flowers give you a small boost of
energy
are you oh my god oh
i have to go help her right the answer
is no don seems to have taken his job as
security guard a little too seriously
tenant spears desire to dominate and
be dominated oh good
golly i guess i have to go pay you a
visit
oh no press the button on the side of
the door look into the camera
okay ah the mind scanner noble
profession
i've unlocked the door come through okay
test me i think you'll see that i am
completely fit i take care of myself
body and mind but i'm happy to comply
with an official mind scanner
alright let's do that i peed my pants
it's cool the other kids locked me in a
closet i respect
i respect their decision fair punishment
that's fair
fair punishment a glass door look at the
thickness of that thing
good luck getting in or out
respects boundaries
[Music]
all right respects boundaries cool good
that's what i'm getting out of this oh
the underside of a boot what a sight
looks brand new the
chats are all fresh who likes being
under the boot yep
that's probably the conclusion to draw
out of this uh you seem perfectly sane
nothing wrong with you drawn to the
aesthetics of control policing aspects
of his personalities led to a
complicated relationship with authority
and punishment
his tenants worry about his power for a
good reason
[Music]
but honestly though is he really insane
can you really even say that he's really
insane because honestly
he seems perfectly in control of himself
and everything that he wants
you know he's very clear about that you
know he's not unclear and he's not
hurting anybody to each their own
saying i declare perfectly
sane entrepreneur no treatment needed
get out of here have a good day
oh get out of here get out of here
[Music]
take care of yours i told you so fit is
a fiddle i know
i know you are time to go back to
mandari
hey sorry that took so long i kind of
forgot about you there
sure like it matters let's have another
go around why don't we okay got
everything
all right let's get this treatment
underway let's do this thing
this one okay one
one am i crazy one just one right one
just one
[Music]
perfect
all right let's get this personality
back up that's low
there we go uh what is that what is that
this one
[Music]
all right let's do this one two
nice nice
let's do it again shall we there we go
close one almost didn't get that oh god
are you really almost out or oh i might
as well just
boost your personality i guess if i can
find it in time
three prongs got it all right i'll be
back for you again because i didn't get
it all done oh
man that sucks see you around bud
okay take care don't move again if you
move again i won't be able to come
fix you your daughter sits next to you
you touch her hair she is gone
well that's that's not good probably not
good
security guard don alonso has bolted the
doors of his building shut and taken his
oh he believes he is saving them from
outside degeneracy a task force has been
dispatched
[Music]
you hereby receive oh fine for nick
oh
breaking news massive explosion on data
tower d1 in the d7 in the deals
at least three people dead in what seems
to be another attack led by the
terrorist group moonrise
[Music]
the constructor describes the attack as
horrifying this is the symptom of the
growing mental problem in the structure
all moonrise members must be located
scanned and treated
of course you moved again damn it oh
look hey chris feinwell chris comes from
a loving home
god i can't believe he seemed fine you
know i guess it should have been
weird i don't know but maybe he's
actually trying to protect them i don't
know everything seems
wrong he has requested his own diagnosis
he entered the family business of
catalog sales for franchise stores and
is engaged to his high school suite
okay he requested his own why does he
want his own
is he fine is he okay is this a waste of
time
look can we talk for a second there's no
need for the skin
i'm cuckoo i'm telling you i can feel it
coco puffs i think about them all the
time how about we just go straight to
the treatment
no jeez what a stickler lighten up
i need to know what's wrong with you
before i can
blip blip blop blop that's what this
feels like to me like blah blah blah
wahoo false statement
[Music]
a new shipment of catalogs smells like
fresh the stack reaches all the way to
the sky
it's crazy it must be crazy to think
this up
works with catalogs works with catalogs
yeah this guy is not crazy that frosting
oh boy i'd recognize it anywhere it's
one of barbara's carrot cakes
monogamous gourmet
[Music]
yep error code three four four five mine
skin inclusive
fine while shows no measurable sign of
insanity apart from a desire to be
diagnosed as insane
well you're saying buddy look i hate to
say this but you're saying
the dreamer no treatment needed
patient declared sane no further action
required sorry
what oh i sound bright your machine is
broken
you just gotta put me back under i'm
telling you no
hey don't leave this isn't right
okay bye thanks pal thank you
i gotta go finish treatment on uh why do
i keep forgetting your name
oh man oh yeah mandari hey how are you
doing sure
yeah okay all right let's let's go again
let's do this whatever the hell we were
doing before let's do that
yeah let's do this uh let's do this
classic style i haven't done this in a
bit
doing nice
ain't that nice pretty nice right not
too bad
not too bad if i do say so myself
honestly that one is pretty quick
wow oh my i see a light this must be
what they call a revelation
i now see where the darkness lies it's
all over the structure but
it's not inside me anymore i have to
spread light
not darkness hey that's great that's
fantastic
good for you yeah i probably should have
diagnosed that other person
your grace you some ben widget bald dash
what is your command mind scan yes your
grace
i will do as you please okay the castle
on the top of the cliff grazing over the
kingdom
no one will ever tear down these walls
they will still be standing ten thousand
years from now
your legacy will be carried on forever
wow uh faithful
[Music]
our spearmen i train them to become the
very best of the continent
nothing can stop them they can pierce
through anything
thinks he trained an army interesting
yo grace it's your golden armor never
seen a more intricate and beautifully
decorated armor
the work of a genius likes armor
yeah am i the emperor the emperor of man
do you think i'm the emperor of man
because that's pretty badass
it seems like benwich's fascination with
medieval times has become his life
he believes himself to be a warlord
stuck in the middle ages
who's to say he's not heretic
ah waiting treatment okay let's uh let's
get you okay
i'm sorry if i failed you here grace
i'll do my best to make up for this
i pledge my life to you i await your
command
sure you do pal sure you do i do need
this one eventually
but do i need it now let's go without it
let's see what happens
[Music]
oh god damn it it is exactly the one i
didn't want
[Music]
who nailed it baby oh oh
god
[Music]
this is this is a nightmare this is
horrible why would anyone do this
why why would you do this to me why why
have you done this to me
oh this is the worst oh this is the
worst
oh why would you do this to me you you
explicitly did this didn't you
oh god
god that's such an ass oh
such an old god
oh god
[Music]
you're fine you're fine you're fine
you're fine you're fine
i'm just gonna give you some of this i'm
gonna give you one of these
oh right to the heart you're gonna love
that boom
love the timing of it love the timing of
it
let's get you some more sanity in there
let's get you you need our personality
personality you
have a lovely personality and i love it
i love that i love your personality
now if only i actually got some of these
things
oh god that's a mistake oh too much
there
don't worry about oh my god too little
[Music]
i am terrible i should have made the
thing i should have made the thing
i should have made the thing hey this is
chris fine well i figured out what
happened yesterday
i didn't read the scans right i'm such a
dummy also i made
i think maybe the strap was loose so
feel free to reach out or stop by and we
can schedule another session
looking forward to it chris weinwell hey
how you doing
uh no hey buddy let's catch some fish at
red lake docks
okay red late docks okay
you heard about the explosion yes that
was us and no
it was not supposed to go down like that
we had it all planned out
one was supposed to get hurt no one was
supposed to get here
those damn officials were waiting for us
damn it we have to be more careful
the name is mona by the way hi
i also have good news we have a friend
inside the
institute a security guard he's seen the
faraday weapon
and your daughter she's okay but they're
keeping her in some sort of reactor
chamber
next to four other test subjects and our
suspicions were right
she's a character carrier of the pulse
we need to establish contact with her
but using our agent is too risky
it must be someone she knows we have to
send you inside
yeah i'm okay with that when the time
comes
we will contact you the security guard
will let you inside the institute
unfortunately you can't get her out just
yet we need you to talk with her
well that seems kind of you
don't get to decide what i do with my
own daughter
okay this fishing trip is over we don't
want to catch a cold
that monastery is a dreamer sounds like
a dangerous plan
why not stick to your profession your
patients are waiting
oak doesn't grow on trees you know
i don't know where kebab come from hello
this is chris fine well again i was just
wondering if you received my message
the walls are closing in i'm going to
snap you better stop by soon
for normality in the mind spiritual
motion smooch chris
um no hi how are you
hi this is a first so you've come to
interview the interviewer
this will be interesting i didn't even
read what your case was vivian leone
nice six head she moves close to you and
puts her hand on yours
her nails resting on the back of your
hand
don't touch me goodbye
her claws dig deep into your hand and
rips it open she tumbles backwards and
lands on all four
she licks your blood off her hands okay
okay we're gonna scan that mind to yours
now
a tiger paw vicious i imagine such a
beautiful thing ripping your throat out
excited by beasts like striped gloves
i mean i guess that's true alfonso
gerron
the editor-in-chief of our competitors
east wall journal
i sure would like to rip his face off
and put that on the front page
violent competitive climber yeah
probably to get to their
targets but violent desires
a blood dripping from the neck of a
large beast triumph
proud veterinarian a taste for blood
[Music]
yeah vivian hunts down a good story at
any cost
when it comes to intimacy she has no
restraints like a cat
hunting mice she will tear anyone apart
until she gets what she wants
sounds pretty sane to me you know not
gonna lie insane
philamenia feli mania personality type
of the entrepreneur
sure whatever you say doctor let's see
where this story goes
i don't like that smile i don't like
that smile
anyway i gotta make this thing
okay cool reflect your decipher's
thoughts of the patients and
disintegrates them with the push of a
button
use the sliders to find a thought then
erase it if it is negative or keep it if
it is positive
okay you got it i don't have time for
you
[Music]
so go away i'm going to bed now
this is fun you know i gotta admit this
is fun like there is
there's an appeal to this it's kind of
like peering into people's minds and
really picking them apart at the base
level
the puzzle aspect is fun too chris fine
here i'm just letting you know that i
intend to find a formal complaint your
methods are doubtful your attitude is
even worse how many dangerous unhinged
individuals
like me do you allow to roam the streets
i'm going to ask you to put me in touch
with your supervisor
this is not over chris yeah whatever you
say man
okay where are you okay 40 away fine
you're
probably closer but you're here i'm
gonna go here all right let's do this i
gotta
give you a de-stress point
okay easy enough
it is kind of directly into your heart
so it's a good thing i have some kind of
timing
let's see about this
oh god i didn't put the thing in there
i didn't put the thing on my menu i
didn't put it there and i
oh i didn't put it there oh i'm an idiot
oh god damn it
god damn it oh my god
oh my god
i didn't put it on my bar can i stop can
i stop
yes we're gonna end it for today oh god
damn it
oh i didn't put it on my bar why didn't
i put it on my bar why didn't i put it
on my bar
i'll see if you spill your guts i'm on
yours
well that wasn't big attention sign you
you
[Music]
oink nice easy peasy
sign you you
what was that you see
sign yep
and that's all we have time for today
hey today went horribly today went real
bad
today was really bad a former patient of
yours mr feinwell has filed a complaint
against you
okay the structure has deemed it invalid
mr feinwell has been assigned mandatory
wall duty
apparently he is loving the change of
scenery
well good everything worked out for the
best then
except for me because i have no money
what are you doing you have to be more
careful whatever you do do not erase the
personality of
your patients we will only warn you once
don't break the people break the
structure
what did i do what did i i didn't erase
anyone's personality
i didn't do any of that what are you
talking about screw you oh
god oh god
oh god i oh
oops i'll come back for you
all right let's get to treatment then
let's do the treaty thing
okay all right let's do uh let's do this
one
[Music]
empty that seems like one
empty get rid of that that's negative
got it out of here get it
out no no no not that one
personality upbeat nations good stuff
[Music]
here we go easy as that
and maybe one of these for good measure
get the stress down get that stretch
down yeah you don't want this
oh i almost had that good god this is
tough
like these guys are so insane it just
takes so much work to get it done
i need so much money okay return to
patient thankfully you're in the exact
same spot which is exactly where you
should be
don't move i'm gonna cure you the
treasury has been
seen better as days spend each point
carefully yep i know
i know all right where's these thoughts
misery get rid of that
get out of here why is this so jumbled
up
god damn it
[Music]
what happened
is there really nothing here for this
i'm not saying anything
devotion there it is jesus that was
what what just happened
but i just what look i need the money
for this like today
i need all the money
[Music]
okay
okay okay why is this being such a pain
in the ass
oh phobia there we go oh i got i gotta
eliminate the bad ones that's right
i gotta keep the good ones i gotta
eliminate the bad ones but it doesn't
count unless i eliminate the bad ones
that one's tough
that one's stupid oh it just occurred to
me that you're a mind scanner i thought
by the way why am i wearing this heavy
armor it's all a bit fuzzy i do feel a
bit silly
thanks for making me think straight
you're welcome thanks for the money
oh this is getting tough
and i'm starting to run out of money i
don't know why i didn't mean to
let her personality die i didn't want
that i didn't even think about it didn't
even notice it when it happened
maybe there's a way that i could make
the this device that kind of restores
personality but probably not
anyway oh man i'm just thinking about
this game just like all the implications
of it the
greater purpose of some mega city
dystopian future but where people quote
unquote live happily
maybe because they don't know anything
else but i don't know it's funky
very strange anyway thank you everybody
so much for watching if you want more of
this let me know in the comments below
but i think i'm gonna keep playing it
anyway
and just like pondering the reality what
are what people's minds and definitions
of insanity and all that stuff
i know it's a game but still it's meant
to make you ponder and it does make me
ponder
so thank you and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you